[Música]
a
escala en parís braulio modo
bienvenidos a escala en parís una
emisión de radio france internacional en
colaboración con la televisión france24
en español hoy vamos a viajar a los
confines de la frontera entre españa y
portugal a galicia famosa por su famosa
catedral de santiago de compostela sus
célebres productos del mar y por sus
historias de tráfico de drogas
concretamente de cocaína nos acompañan
en esta ocasión gimnasio nacho carretero
autor del libro fariña una historia de
investigación sobre el tráfico de
cocaína en galicia traducido al francés
recientemente por las ediciones de
desert mit y nacho bienvenido a esta
escala en parís muchas gracias hombres
que se halló comenzar una cuestión que
es precisa su libro fariña fue prohibido
durante varios meses en españa usted fue
acusado que hicieron quisieron hacer un
proceso quien bloqueaba la publicación
de estos libros de este libro cuáles
intereses con los que usted afectó con
la publicación de fariña bueno es una
pregunta interesante porque a día de hoy
desconozco el motivo por el cual el
libro fue bueno en términos jurídicos en
españa sería secuestrado es decir
prohibida su venta su publicación
su impresión esto ocurrió el libro fue
publicado a finales de 2015 y en 2018 un
ex alcalde de un pueblo de galicia que
había sido procesado por narcotráfico
porque bueno esto nos años 80 era algo
común que alcaldes fueron también
contrabandistas o narcotraficantes pues
presentó una querella por injurias y
ofensas y bueno pues la jueza de turno
pues estimó que había que prohibir el
libro mientras se decidía la sentencia
así que bueno durante cinco meses estuvo
prohibido yo creo que se debió si soy
sincero a un error judicial pues por
sobrecarga de trabajo o por lo que sea
por negligencia pero no creo que hubiera
unos resortes de poder o una teoría de
la conspiración un poco ahí escondida
detrás yo creo que simplemente fue un
error judicial que todavía a día de hoy
en españa nos seguimos preguntando por
qué ocurrió porque esto es algo hay que
decir que no sucede en españa tan
interesante la historia que se volvió
precisamente una serie de televisión de
galicia es una zona extremadamente era
una zona extremadamente pobre eso desde
muchísimos años atrás durante la época
de la guerra civil o al final de la
guerra civil española la gente desde la
localidad
y sobre todo al tráfico de cigarrillos
esto ha evolucionado se pasa es una
actividad bastante lucrativa pero
evoluciona muy rápido de el tráfico de
cigarrillos al hachís y luego a la
cocaína cómo es posible que esto se haya
desarrollado tan largo tiempo más de 60
años y en una buena parte de ella sin
intervención realmente del estado
español
bueno pues porque el contrabando era
algo beneficioso para la gente en
galicia como bien dices galicia era una
zona muy castigada en posguerra era una
zona muy empobrecida y utilizaba el
contrabando para para adquirir pues
primero material de primera necesidad
como medicinas como gasolina después
tabaco y esto generaba empleo daba
riqueza entonces los contrabandistas
eran vistos como hombres benefactores
sociales como líderes sociales que
tenían contactos al más alto nivel
político policial y en el respetado
socialmente de manera que ni los
políticos ni las autoridades
consideraban necesario intervenir y
desmontar un negocio que era bien visto
cuando la mayoría de estos clanes o
algunos de estos clanes y familias
dieron saltó al narcotráfico a
principios de los años 80 ya tenían toda
esta infraestructura toda esta red y
todo este respaldo social completamente
consolidado de manera que cuando el
estado se dio cuenta ya era demasiado
tarde y ya había pues la verdad una red
mafiosa en galicia instaurada y todo
mundo metía la mano ahí por lo menos
hasta los años al principio de los años
80 y una anécdota que punto usted que me
parece bastante significativa son
pescadores entonces es la virgen del
carmen la patrona de la gente que cree
en esto hay la fiesta del pueblo y él
tiene que llegar un desembarco de hachís
y los narcotraficantes le dicen al cura
que suspenda la fiesta que la paz con un
día el cura lo prueba y después que
sucede sí porque además durante las
fiestas del carmen salen todos los
barcos en una especie de desfile por por
la ría gallega y entonces claro
necesitaban las embarcaciones para él
para desembarcar descargar el alijo y
entonces el cura accedió a retrasar un
día el festejo la celebridad cuando ya
no era el día que le correspondía es
toda
esto da una idea del poder que llegaron
a tener de ellos decidían hasta hasta
las festividades y bueno si esto habla
de que de que efectivamente durante los
años 80 y 90 los grandes jefes los
señores de la droga en galicia
eran impunes eran intocables y tenían
control en todos los ámbitos desde el
político al social pasando por por el
institucional y hasta eran presidentes
de los equipos de fútbol en la costa
gallega hay una cosa que es importante
que la gente tenga en consideración el
ingreso de españa' a la entonces
comunidad económica europea lo que
después se convirtió en la unión europea
cambia la situación es decir españa
tiene que adaptar sus leyes y esto
implica un paso adelante precisamente en
esta lucha contra el tráfico en este
momento todavía de hachís aunque ya
empieza a llegar el tráfico de cocaína
si entonces en todos los órdenes del
ingreso de españa en la unión europea
cambia la legislación
cambia también los medios y cambia las
fronteras hasta ese momento pues los
contrabandistas y narcotraficantes se
podían refugiar en portugal o en francia
cruzando la la frontera y en ese momento
cambia todo todo el paradigma y el
contrabando empieza a ser un delito
perseguido porque un momento la
legislación española no contemplaba el
contrabando como un delito por lo tanto
la impunidad era era enorme no sólo eso
sino que antes del ingreso en la unión
europea el narcotráfico y el contrabando
tenían el mismo castigo por lo tanto
ante un riesgo igual pues el beneficio
era mucho mayor si se traficaba con
cocaína o con hachís en lugar de con
tabaco y de ahí que muchos de estos
jefes muchas de estas familias dieran el
salto en los años 80 a la droga y
heredarán todas esas infraestructuras
todo ese respaldo social que venía de
décadas anteriores del contrabando
haciendo que el que bueno que digamos
que la narcocultura o la actividad
normalizada del narcotráfico se
perpetuará y todavía hoy en día en
galicia sigue siendo una actividad
demasiado presente desde usted había
bastante impunidad en ese momento no es
sino en los años 90 con el juez baltasar
cada persona que va a realizarse la
primera gran operación para tratar de
controlar esta situación háblenos de
este caso porque es bastante
significativo la operación nécora
operación nécora eso es es la primera
operación el primer movimiento que
finalmente el estado decide hacer contra
las familias contra las redes del
narcotráfico en galicia y creo que es
importante y yo lo cuento en el libro
destacar que esa reacción del estado
viene promovida por una reacción social
en galicia encabezada por las madres
cuando la droga empieza a hacer estragos
en la juventud en galicia en lo que en
galicia conocemos como la generación
perdida toda una generación de jóvenes
nacidos en los años 70 que empieza a
caer víctima de la masiva presencia de
droga estas madres reaccionan y dicen
estos no son los benefactores sociales
que eran estos no son los personajes que
nos quieren vender que son positivos
para nuestra sociedad estos son
criminales y se enfrentan a ellos aparte
de una manera muy valiente porque en
aquella época nadie se enfrentaba a esta
gente y este grupo de madres al
principio muy reducido les plantan cara
empiezan a pelear contra ellos se les
une
progresivamente el resto de la sociedad
hasta que a los políticos y autoridades
no les queda más remedio que hacer caso
de lo que la sociedad está exigiendo qué
es
y ahí aparece el juez garzón y la
operación nécora se desarrolla desde
madrid también esto nos da una idea de
que en galicia era imposible los
tentáculos y las redes del narcotráfico
llegaban a todos los ámbitos policiales
y políticos por tanto si se intervenía
tenía que ser desde la confidencialidad
y desde madrid como así fue son las
madres del geta
érguete significaría como levántate en
gallego y que plantear dos con cientos
muy precisos que trabajos y drogas no y
ni locas ni terroristas somos madres
realistas es este eslogan de tabacos y
droga no nos habla de que el contrabando
de tabaco era algo plenamente aceptado
en galicia porque estaba en el
imaginario que generaba riqueza le daba
empleo a la gente joven ante una zona
como es galicia que estaba algo
abandonada por el estado y entonces este
eslogan nos deja claro si queréis ser
contrabandistas por nosotros todo bien
pero drogas no porque nos están haciendo
daño y ese cambio de paradigma es lo que
ha cambiado el paisaje en galicia hoy en
día los narcotraficantes existen son
poderosos en galicia pero viven en el
anonimato y son considerados como
criminales ya hay una línea roja entre
la sociedad gallega y la criminalidad
organizada cuando hace 20 o 30 años esta
línea roja era muy difusa y los
narcotraficantes estaban en las
instituciones y eran gente respetada y
bien vista medio siglo de historia
porque eso es lo que cuenta
fariña precisamente es sin duda alguna
apasionante esta cuestión los años 90
traen el inicio del siglo trae una
situación una nueva generación de
narcotraficantes muy metidos ya
concretamente en el tráfico de cocaína
no hemos hablado precisamente dentro del
vínculo entre los de los colombianos la
magia de españa' y otras mafias en
europa que usted aborda en su libro un
metro carreteros y al final galicia como
región de españa y no deja de ser un
eslabón más en la cadena que es el
narcotráfico a nivel global no se puede
pretender eliminar el narcotráfico de
una zona concreta
cuando se trata de un negocio global que
parte de colombia principalmente y otros
países latinoamericanos pasa por
carteles que lo distribuyen
transportistas que lo introducen en
europa y bandas organizadas que lo
compran y lo distribuyen por toda europa
en todos estos como una cadena global en
la cual galicia forma parte
sobre todo como transportistas los
narcos gallegos están especializados en
introducir la cocaína y el hachís en
tierra y lo suelen hacer por el método
de planeadoras que son estas lanchas
rápidas muy potentes que pilotan de
maravilla porque el conocimiento en
galicia del mar es muy profundo y cuesta
en cientos de miles de euros casi un
millón de euros a 600 les hablamos de
lanchas que pueden superar los 12 ó 15
metros de eslora
10-12 motores a 130 kilómetros en el
agua del mar para que nos hagamos una
idea son lanchas que pueden plantarse en
mitad del océano atlántico en apenas 12
13 horas desde la costa española con lo
cual son embarcaciones potentísimas que
cargan con los fardos de cocaína y luego
descargan en en tierra y la buena la
singularidad del narcotráfico en galicia
es que son muy eficaces de manera que
los grandes cárteles colombianos
latinoamericanos tienen alianzas muy
sólidas confían mucho en el transporte
en galicia de ahí que estas alianzas se
están perpetuando y hayan llegado al día
de hoy digamos que la desgracia del
narcotráfico en galicia es que es muy
bueno es muy eficaz y por tanto sigue
siguen confiando en los transportistas
gallegos para introducir la droga ayuda
hay varias cosas que usted menciona es
el libro está lleno de dijéramos de
anécdotas bastante interesantes de esa
primera operación después siguen una
serie de operaciones con nombres muy
ilustrados y imaginativos y se puede
decir al mismo tiempo de la primera
operación donde se detienen a 60
personas después se han detenido a casi
20.000 personas más y lo que usted
menciona es que todos los especialistas
le dicen tal y como está esta es una
batalla por lo menos hasta ahora perdida
evidentemente los narcotraficantes
perfeccionan sus métodos y da la
impresión que la autoridad que el estado
simple va detrás de esto así es
lo que hablamos de los años 80 y 90 era
un paisaje en el cual los grandes
contrabandistas y narcotraficantes eran
intocables y en esa impunidad vivían
conducían grandes coches vivían en
mansiones cenaban en los mejores
restaurantes y tenían los más altos
contactos políticos y empresariales con
la operación nécora del juez garzón se
mandó un mensaje el estado empieza a
vigilar es el estado va a reaccionar
entonces los narcos también aprenden un
poco esa lección y cambian el perfil hoy
son discretos hoy son
invisibles y son casi anónimos entonces
la percepción es con muchas veces la
percepción es que el narcotráfico en
galicia es una cosa del pasado la
realidad es que los narcos de hoy aunque
invisibles son más poderosos que nunca y
mueven más cantidad de droga que nunca
pues llegamos ya al final de esta escala
en parís no me quede sino agradecerle a
ignacio nacho carretero su presencia
dios muy agradecido a ustedes les damos
una próxima cita la semana entrante en
otra escala en parís
[Música]